comment ça va aujourd'hui regardez ce
qu'on vient parler on vient parler
d'écran on vient parler de technologie
on vient parler de Samsung pourquoi on
est MWC et Samsung présente des trucs
super intéressant alors c'est quoi je
vous explique ce sont des conseils des
prototypes d'écran pour venir voir
qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir faire au
niveau des écrans qui se plient d'un
côté de l'autre qui s'enroule bref plein
de technologie extrêmement intéressantes
on va essayer d'en train de percevoir le
futur des écrans de Samsung ici
OMW c'est est-ce que vous êtes prêts
est-ce que vous êtes chaud parce que
sans sujet que je voulais faire lorsque
j'étais au CES à Las Vegas on avait pas
accès c'était uniquement sur invitation
dans un hôtel frustrant et là on peut le
voir à Barcelone et je suis tellement
heureux par vous présenter allez on y va
[Musique]
alors la première techno c'est le flex S
c'est quoi le flex S et bien en fait si
vous connaissez les écrans de Samsung
vous connaissez notamment le Samsung
Galaxy Z fold le zflip le zflip il vient
se diminuer en taille il y a plus petit
pour se mettre dans une poche et le Z
fold on vient augmenter la surface on
est sur une petite tablette et ça c'est
très chouette et bien sauf que si on
plie une partie on peut plier de voir
plus si affinités et là on va venir lier
trois comme un accordéon donc vous le
pliez en deux et vous pliez de l'autre
côté c'est le flex s alors soyons clair
tout de suite il y a pas de produit fini
qui va arriver le flex s reste une
démonstration monte parce que Samsung
peut proposer mais si on vient se
projeter un peu dans les usages et si on
veut regarder un peu plus loin c'est un
sujet qui est extrêmement intéressant
parce que ça permet de faire plus
d'agrandir avoir une très grande carte
une grosse tablette lorsque vous l'avez
c'est très grand dans la main et c'est
génial et lorsque vous voulez plus petit
le mettre dans une poche dans un sac on
peut alors attention aujourd'hui techno
sont quand même un peu grand ça fait des
trucs un peu épais un peu mastoc mais
une fois de plus c'est essayer d'encre
apercevoir l'avenir donc ça c'est plutôt
cool ça vous fait une espèce de pliure
en forme de S vous voyez un petit S qui
vient se dessiner on peut imaginer
lorsqu' puis effectivement bien avoir un
petit appareil avec un écran 6,5 pouces
qui est déjà très très grand et lorsque
vous l'ouvrez vous avez un 11 pouces 12
pouces et peut-être même plus on peut
faire un S mais on pourrait faire
carrément des W et faire plein de
lettres donc ça je trouve ça assez
marrant ah ils vont ensuite le flex g
alors ils aiment bien les noms en Flex
Philippe fold salut j'aime bien les
Samsung alors le flex g c'est exactement
le même système de pliure sauf que au
lieu de l'avoir en forme de S et bien ça
vous fait un espèce de forme U ça aurait
pu être le flex U ou le flex V non ils
ont fait le flex g très bizarre pourquoi
pas en fait le truc c'est quoi c'est que
vous avez un très grand écran que vous
venez plier d'un côté comme ça et de
l'autre côté comme ça ça vous permet
d'avoir un espèce de smartphone tablette
pour pouvoir venir replier pour gagner
en termes d'utilité en termes de
rangement alors on peut imaginer
pourquoi pas un écran au dos lorsqu'il
est fermé un peu comme le flex s j'en
sais rien en tout cas des écrans on peut
en coller tous les côtés mais c'est
juste pour montrer le système de pliure
on va pouvoir venir faire d'un côté et
de l'autre c'est une fois de plus se
dire que si on peut le faire pourquoi
pas le faire alors plus complice des
smartphones on peut également payer des
ordinateurs alors ça je veux déjà
montrer chez Asus sur le Zenbook fold me
semble-t-il c'est le nom donc on arrive
sur le flax note le flex note c'est quoi
et bien c'est un ordinateur un énorme
tablette que vous voulez que vous venez
pliez pour l'emmener partout avec vous
imaginez effectivement comme je vous ai
montré chez Asus vous l'ouvrez vous avez
un grand écran où on peut venir mettre
un petit clavier sans fil devant comme
un fait Asus vous le repliez c'est plus
facile à emmener avec vous très
facilement c'est une fois de plus
comment utiliser la technologie de
l'olyte qui vient se plier ici et le
mettre sur un écran d'ordinateur ni plus
ni moins sur des choses qui existent
déjà on l'a déjà vu des produits finis
dans le commerce à quasiment 4000 euros
mais ça peut être en intérêt pour
l'avenir peut-être que ça pourrait vous
intéresser vous d'abord un ordinateur
qui vient se plier pour gagner en
rangement c'est tout l'intérêt ici c'est
la modularité c'est l'usage mixte que je
trouve assez intéressant ici on arrive
ensuite sur le slide double solo alors
on connaît les écrans qui se plie d'un
côté de l'autre en G en U en S on le
sait il y a aucun problème mais
puisqu'on peut venir les plier on peut
également venir les enrouler alors on
l'a déjà vu ça notamment chez oppo il y
a peut-être deux ans je vous l'avais
montré que Samsung ici propose également
cette technologie même si ils l'ont pas
tout de suite eux mis directement dans
des smartphones et dans des objets
peut-être d'ailleurs que l'enroulable
que propose au poste un écran Samsung
allez savoir je sais pas mais peut-être
donc ça veut dire que vous allez pouvoir
l'enrouler donc ici le produit qu'on
nous montre vous avez une grande
tablette et on voit qu'on a des petites
parties séparées et on voit qu'on peut
venir l'étirer d'un côté et de donc vous
prenez votre tablette vous venez
l'étirer vous venez l'agrandir pour en
faire un plus grand parchemin c'est
vraiment l'idée du parchemin ici de
l'enroulable à l'intérieur il va donc
venir se replier sur lui-même rentrer à
l'intérieur et lorsque vous l'ouvrez
vous avez une plus grande tablette et le
truc qui est intéressant c'est que le
contenu dynamiquement va venir également
s'adapter il y a aucun intérêt à avoir
des pixels allumés lorsque votre
tablette smartphone est enroulé ça
viendrait consommer de l'énergie ça nous
reste strictement aucun sens donc
lorsqu'il est fermé et bien
mécaniquement il le sait va donc
éteindre toute la partie intérieure et
lorsque vous l'ouvrez et bien ils
viennent s'allumer on est une fois de
plus dans l'idée de la modularité ici
avec ici de l'enroulable alors Samsung
display c'est effectivement des écrans
qui se plient d'un côté de l'autre parce
que je sais pas si vous le savez mais
quand on parle de Samsung on parle
souvent de Samsung électronique ce qui
est la partie qui s'occupe du Consumer
du grand public qui vient vendre des
produits que vous achetez qu'on achète
qu'on a tous notamment regardez le chez
dans ma poche ici le Samsung Galaxy S23
ultra et toute la famille de smartphone
de produits télé et compagnie mais en
fait un grand groupe qu'on connaît qui
est en Corée vous avez Samsung tout en
et vous avez différentes divisions
Samsung électroniques est une division
et on a également une note division qui
est Samsung display en fait Samsung
electronic se fournit auprès de Samsung
display pour avoir ses dalles pour les
télés pour les smartphones et compagnie
donc il cherche toujours à travailler à
propos de nouvelles technologies aller
plus loin au niveau on va sur les
smartphones aujourd'hui on est sur la
dynamique à molette 2x ça va continuer à
évoluer dans les temps à venir il y a
une techno qui évolue et qui est
intéressant et qu'on a vu chez Samsung
sur le Galaxy Z3 Z34 zedfall 2 3
également et bien c'est la caméra qui
est sous l'écran qui est caché à
l'intérieur de votre smartphone alors
souvenez-vous je sais pas si vous avez
vu lorsque vous ouvrez votre smartphone
votre Galaxy Z3 si vous l'avez mais pas
les générations d'avant et bien vous ne
voyez pas ici votre caméra lorsque vous
êtes en train de regarder un film une
série non vous voyez uniquement votre
contenu alors si vous regardez de près
on voit qu'il y a une petite différence
parce que la densité de pixel
aujourd'hui est pas énorme énorme mais
ça me saoule travail dessus et il nous
le montre ici avec effectivement une
comparaison entre une technologie dans
cette pixel un peu plus faible qu'un peu
plus ancienne et l'autre avec une
densité de pixel un peu plus élevée ou
là on va carrément plus du tout voir
cette caméra c'est le but c'est l'idée à
l'avenir c'est de la rendre totalement
invisible alors attention que ça intégré
dans le Z fold 4 et on le voit ça
fonctionne c'est quand même plutôt pas
mal mais j'ai vu d'autres fabricants
j'ai vu notamment ZTE bon je sais pas si
c'est une dalle Samsung chez ZTE mais la
danse c'est pixel est très élevé ce qui
fait que la caméra on la voit quasiment
pas donc ça c'est vachement cool et
super intéressant donc ça ça va arriver
dans les temps à venir au niveau des
smartphones parce que si vous regardez
aujourd'hui je reprends une fois de plus
mon galaxy S23 ultra et bien vous voyez
ici j'ai ma caméra qui ressort on peut
pas la louper franchement aller au
milieu on la voit et bien l'idée à
l'avenir c'est que toutes ces caméras là
on les voit plus donc une fois de plus
Samsung me montre ici Samsung display
nous montre cette techno comment est-ce
qu'ils viennent l'affaire évoluer tout
en sachant que le point qui est
extrêmement important et pour l'instant
c'est pas ouf que ce soit chez elle ou
chez Samsung c'est-à-dire que la qualité
de la caméra est pas forcément là donc
il y a encore un peu de boulot à faire
pour que la qualité soit vraiment
totalement maîtrisée que ce soit
réellement intéressant en tout cas les
techno est là et la techno évolué ça
c'est chouette alors avoir des écrans
qui se plient c'est bien on trouve ça
chouette maintenant on va se dire dans
le temps ça va donner quoi quelle est la
durabilité parce que effectivement vous
le prenez vous le pliez c'est sympa mais
on va se dire on va aller jusqu'au alors
moi je vais vous le dire à titre
personnel on est à la maison galaxie zip
3 depuis 1 an et demi deux ans à peu
près on commence à voir légère petite
trace au niveau de la pliure mais aucun
problème l'écran marche bien ça
fonctionne bien on en reparlera
d'ailleurs très bientôt et bien Samsung
ici une machine qui lui permet d'ouvrir
de fermer d'ouvrir de fermer d'ouvrir de
fermer et de comptabiliser le nombre de
fois où il y a eu des ouvertures et des
fermetures pour bien déjà d'une tester
le produit et après certifié que c'est
complètement possible et qu'on peut y
arriver sans aucun problème il vous
montre ici la démo plus de 200000 fois
en fait l'idée je pense même avec
beaucoup plus loin 300000 voire 400000
aujourd'hui il y a des produits qui sont
certifiés jusqu'à plus de 400000 fois
c'est ce qu'on a vu sur le oppo finden
de flip si vous vous souvenez on en a
parlé il y a pas très très longtemps et
bien ça me saoule donc créateur de dalle
à l'obligation de venir faire ses tests
et de regarder ça fonctionne donc vous
voyez il nous montre la machine on le
ferme on l'ouvre on le ferme alors vous
vous allez pas l'ouvrir et le fermer de
la même manière chez vous mécaniquement
parce qu'à force de l'ouvrir et le
fermer comme ça vous allez créer de la
friction fatalement et vous allez créer
aussi de la chauffe donc si là en
l'ouvrant et en fermant tout le temps ça
crée de la chauffe et ça tient et
absolument aucun problème vous pouvez
être sûr que chez vous ça fonctionne et
ça ira parfaitement bien alors qu'est-ce
qu'il faut dire retenir ici de toute
cette technologie Flex s Flex g Flex
note slidable solo on a l'UPC plus je
vous ai pas dit non parce qu'il était un
petit peu habitable au niveau une caméra
sous l'écran des différentes
technologies que vous avez ici et bien
c'est que Samsung continue à travailler
sur ces différentes technos et ce qu'on
voit là sont des choses qui sont
abouties fini probablement livrés à des
partenaires peut-être que au pot
d'ailleurs est un partenaire qui a cette
technologie Samsung il est évident
qu'ils en ont beaucoup plus mais qu'il
les cachent ils les gardent pour eux
pour les produits qui sortiront dans les
années à venir on va pas venir montrer
ce qui est top secret aujourd'hui mais
ce qu'on peut voir ici en tant que
professionnel dans un salon
professionnel est-ce que le grand public
voir c'est que le pliable l'enroulable
le modulaire et bien continue son petit
bonhomme de chemin il va continuer à
évoluer et à se retrouver de plus en
plus dans nos poches dans nos sacs dans
nos sacs à main dans nos bandouilleurs
dans nos saibadins bref on fait ce que
vous voulez au niveau de la tenue
vestimentaire la question aujourd'hui
c'est de réduire l'épaisseur de réduire
l'encombrement pour que ce soit pas plus
contraignant qu'un gros smartphone qu'on
va venir mettre dans notre poche
aujourd'hui c'est pas encore le cas on
voit qu'on a des produits qui sont quand
même relativement un peu épais si vous
regardez le Galaxy Z fold le Galaxy Z
flip c'est différent parce qu'on vient
de diviser un petit coup on vient
réduire la taille ça fonctionne il n'y a
pas de souci et voyez la technologie est
en marche je trouve ça une fois de plus
extrêmement intéressant donc on
continuera à regarder ça ensemble on
continuera à parler avec ces écrans qui
se plient pour moi 2023 c'est l'année de
la démocratisation des il y en a de plus
en plus on va des acteurs majeurs comme
oppo qui arrive d'être plus en plus qui
vont arriver il y a déjà Motorola avec
son Razer ils vont continuer à emmener
d'autres produits ils ont montré ici une
technologie d'enroulable qui est aussi
super intéressantes même si c'est qu'un
concept fun et que on va pas forcément
aller bien loin là-dessus mais en tout
cas la modularité est en marche parce
que ce qu'on connaît aujourd'hui des
smartphones un peu classique et bien on
est arrivé sur un form factor qui est
extrêmement mature donc pour réinventer
l'histoire pour apporter un peu
d'innovation et un peu de progrès on est
obligé de passer par la modularité et à
terme on fera disparaître le produit et
on le voit ici à MWC de nombreuses
marques proposent des lunettes notamment
Xiaomi qui a présenté des lunettes de
réalité augmentée au pot tu as sa
deuxième version il y a également TCL
qui travaille dessus pourquoi c'est pour
réinventer l'interface homme machine
pour une fois de plus aller à la
modularité pour une fois de plus se
libérer les mains et pouvoir avoir du
contenu pour pouvoir piloter des choses
pour avoir accès à des informations les
mains libres et ne pas s'embêter donc
vous voyez la technologie nous permet
tout ça nous permet de nous libérer de
ces contrats et je trouve ça juste
extraordinaire d'ailleurs vous dites-moi
ce que vous en pensez qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette technologie qu'on trouve
ici chez Samsung c'est des choses qui
vous intéressent c'est des choses sur
lesquelles vous pourriez aller est-ce
que vous avez déjà adopté un smartphone
pliant un smartphone pliable si oui
lequel vous plaît et quelle technologie
pourrait venir vous séduire ici est-ce
que c'est le truc qui nous fait une
espèce de vague est-ce qu'on est sur le
GS qu'on est plutôt sur le slidable sur
l'enroulable marquez moi ça en bas dans
les commentaires et nous on se retrouve
très bientôt bien évidemment pour
continuer à parler de cette technologie
et de bien plus encore voilà je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous et à
bientôt bisous Ciao
[Musique]